thank you all over Israel here in Tel
Aviv and elsewhere we are protesting
against the horrific program committed
by the extremist settlers in the West
Bank yesterday they came because they
have the support of the government we
came to raise our voice in protest
Jewish and Palestinian citizens of
Israel to say end the occupation and
Advance towards an israeli-palestinian
peace
thank you
foreign
for this government to bring out all the
settlements on settlers who are inside
the Palestinian territories and to
demand peace for everybody and end of
the occupation
[Music]
every week settlers attacked us and
broke our Windows last year then an aid
agency installed this metal fencing it's
our only protection but it's like prison
[Music]